when I entered politics I actually had  conquered my fear of dying otherwise I  would not have entered politics because  I came in to stand up against the entire  status quo I came came to fight  corruption today the entire political  Spectrum 16 parties on one side and I'm  on the other side and because this was  the status quo which is 60 years of her  last 62 years half has been ruled by  military and half by these two families  so I came to fight these two families  and this is really what I've I've done  and they have made so much money out of  this that they obviously clearly someone  like me is a threat and and that's why  this uh foreign-backed conspiracy  involving local players took place now I  know that they would try to my life has  had various threats over a period of  time but this time I found out about  this conspiracy so I went public